the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so are we ready to go
any questions on 1806 5 so it will be as
I said before a mixture of linear
algebra and math questions along with
online using the material ok so I'm in
this first week or two reviewing the
highlights of linear algebra and I've
reached this point to remember well so
we I just said two words about
multiplying matrices by using column
times row as a as a way to do it and now
I want to illustrate that by the five
key factorizations of matrices okay so
what are they and do you recognize them
everybody uses those letters in fact
those some of those letters like lu or
QR would be the most used matlab
commands in linear algebra so a April Lu
I'll maybe say something I'll develop
today but it's about elimination
solving linear systems so that's always
the start of a linear algebra course but
I it will go fast here I just want to
show you a different way to get to L
times u lower triangular times upper
triangular probably you've seen that
those triangular matrices so do you know
what QR is what's QR about these squares
is the big application the factorization
so what kind of a matrix gets that
letter Q orthogonal the columns are
orthogonal often orthonormal so
orthogonal means they're perpendicular
to each other and or so normal means
they're unit vectors so that that is so
so Q often represents a matrix with
orthonormal columns so so you we could
say gram-schmidt if you want to remember
a couple of old-timers who whose
algorithm produces Q and R how about
this one this is really a central one in
math pure math applied math everywhere
applications so S stands for symmetric
so this is a special factorization for
symmetric matrices and you can see that
it's symmetric this lambda is the
diagonal eigenvalue matrix always lambda
for 4i ghen values
q is like that q different q of course
that q you can find sort of just
straight forward from gram-schmidt this
q involved has the eigenvectors so you
don't find eigenvectors without some
extra work okay so that's eigenvectors
yeah so that would be worth expanding so
here are the eigenvectors of
of the matrix sn2 them normalized here
are the eigenvalues lambda 1 to lambda n
and here are the eigenvectors now
transposed okay so remind me of the
great fact about two facts I guess one
fact about the eigenvalues and one fact
about the eigenvectors this is like an
important fact in a statement in linear
algebra what is what do we know about
the eigenvectors oh well i guess i'm
giving it away
the eigenvectors are orthogonal that's
very important
make some matrices well they're
beautiful matrices they're the kings of
linear algebra Q's are the queens in my
opinion orthogonal matrices are the
queens of symmetric matrices are the
king so so these are orthonormal
eigenvectors and the key point an
important point that's implicit here is
there are n of them there's a complete
set the matrix can be diagonalized and
those well what's special about the
eigenvalues other matrices could be Q
lambda Q transpose but symmetric
matrices are something additional about
lambda so they're all real so eigen
values are real and eigen vectors are
orthonormal can be chosen orthonormal
can be chosen I just have to say okay
good good good oh now maybe I'll use
that as an example of matrix
multiplication so let me just do that
here simple matrix multiplications but
it makes the point so Q lambda Q
transpose okay well what was my point
about matrix multiplication let me be
it really involved two matrices here I
unfortunately have three so I'm gonna
have to squeeze lambda in with one of
the cubes too to see it nicely as two
matrices so they just do that yeah there
now I've made two matrices that was easy
okay now what's the rule and in the
first notes this was a and this was B
and when you multiply two matrices the
rule is this is columns of Q lambda
times rows of Q transpose I'm
multiplying columns by rows and so it's
a column vector times a row vector and
that gives us a matrix so each and it's
a special matrix what so this is a
column this is a row and when I multiply
n by 1 times 1 by n I get an N by n
matrix and it's pretty special and what
is the special fact about I'm sort of
recalling from last time
what's special about a column times a
row it's rank is special it's rank is 1
it all its column space well the only
column around is this one so all columns
are multiples of this guy all rows are
multiples of this guy as we could see
from an example so they just do an
example 1 2 times 3 4 to take a random
example so that would give us 3 4 6 8
I'm sure enough the columns are
multiples of 1 2 the rows are multiples
of 3 4 and the rank is 1 okay so those
are the building blocks now I want to
build something so here we go so this is
a sum of rank some
of Rank 1 sum of column times row so I
take column 1 times Row 1 that's my
first thing in the sum so column 1 of
that so you see I had to sneak the
lambda end to have just just two factors
so what's column 1 of Q lambda oh that's
a good question
so column 1 of Q is Q 1 the first
eigenvector but now I I'm multiplying by
this diagonal matrix do you see in your
mind what's the first column of Q lambda
just think about that a second so here's
we can steal any little corner for for
for a matrix ok so here's Q 1 and the
rest of the columns and then here's
lambda 1 and that's Q lambda so I'm
putting those together and I'm asking
what's the first column of the answer
and you see how that works
it's Q 1 lambda 1 exactly that lambda 1
will multiply Q 1 these other lambdas
multiplied later columns so the first
column is lambda 1 times Q 1 right so
that's it's the first guy lambda 1 Q 1
and then the first row of this will be Q
1 transpose that's the first guy in our
sum of N Things and let me put the next
one in the last 1 lambda 2 Q 2 Q 2
transpose and lambda n qn QN transpose
that's really a nice way to write to
break up the product Q lambda Q
transpose this is called the spectral
theorem so that's the symmetric that's s
that's s there is that so that's the
we've broken up s into rank one pieces
that's that's like a constant theme and
these write one pieces are quite special
because they're symmetric Q 1 Q 1
transpose will be symmetric and oh so
can we so so let's just
I follow the rule for multiplying
matrices but maybe I could just check
that it's the right thing that it came
out right so what do I mean by checking
I guess I'll just check about s times Q
1 so look at if this thing times the
first eigenvector and what do I get
ok so you'll like this so there's I've
split up s into a sum of Rank 1 pieces
and that splitting is you see it all
over it's really showing you what the
pieces of the symmetric matrix are and
now I'm just gonna check that that's a
correct correct formula for s so I'll
multiply it by Q 1 and I'm hoping to get
the right thing and what do I actually
get if I multiply this whole business
times Q 1 I get lambda 1 Q 1 Q 1
transpose that's the first guy times by
Q 1 plus right I'm multiplying this by Q
1 and this first term gave me that and
what does the next term give me put put
me out of my misery here it's uh I'm
looking for this thing to simplify like
mad okay so what's the second term when
I'm
supply this guy by q1 what do I get zero
that's right that's what we want and
when I multiply the last guy by q1 I get
0 because the Q's are orthogonal so this
is all I get
and then so I don't need this plus
anymore that's it and then what can I do
to improve that or is that a little
somewhat repetitive formula for the
answer what do I want to do finally I
want to remember that the Q's are
normalized their unit vectors so what
does that tell me here to one principal
q1 transpose times Q 1 this is just what
it sits so that's what normalized means
that the length squared is the length
the length of the vector squared and
it's 1 so I can cancel that term and I'm
getting the right answer that's all I
that's all this was about I was just
checking and wanted to see how it would
fall out and it falls right out that
this formula is the correct matrix s
because it's got the right eigenvectors
qs and it's got the right eigenvalues
lambda so it's got to be the right
matrix yes is that ok that's a like a
first example to see how this splitting
into rank ones gives you back what you
expect easily enough it gives you the
information you expect okay so that's
the symmetric eigen value picture for
symmetric matrices and we'll see it
again it's it's well all five of these
are big are important I don't know if
you know this
but it's going to be a foundational
factorization for this course and for
all of data science do you know it's
named so what does it mean first of all
just just a comment on this and then
we'll save it for a couple of weeks so
this U is actually an orthogonal matrix
and so is V so it has it has two
orthogonal matrices so that's why people
called them U and V rather than q1 and
q2 which was like too much just get
subscripts so orthogonal times diagonal
times orthogonal let me say orthogonal
diagonal or sonogram and 1806 would as
of now reach this topic because it's
jumped up in importance and it's called
singular value decomposition well those
are long words or everybody calls it the
SVD the singular value decomposition
the point is it's it's the it works for
every matrix rectangular matrices
there's no issue of does it have enough
eigenvectors or not that's an issue here
well it's an issue here not every matrix
has got enough eigenvectors to make that
work every matrix that one works because
instead of one set of eigenvectors it's
got two matrices two different sets of
singular vectors oh we'll we'll see that
that's that's important okay
so that's a that's really a quick
overview of fundamental factorizations
and I'd like to say just another word
about elimination a equal Lu and then
we'll leave it leave it alone
so elimination yeah do you remember that
that first the beginning of linear
algebra when you're solving ax equal B
you do these row operations
can I just what I want to say is all
those row operations that you that you
do are perfectly expressed by L times U
and so that that's a key point in 1806
but I have a different way to look at it
so that's what I wanted to show you I
have a I want to show you a sum of rank
one's a row times column it fits in
today so so I just like to see why does
a matrix invertible this is a square
matrix now and invertible and it factors
if all goes well with elimination and
the pivots are nonzero
it factors into lower triangular times
upper triangular so that's a key step
that that is that MATLAB would do with
lvo event would produce those two
factors now I want to do them in a
column times row way which I just
realized late was there was a neat way
to do it so can I take a matrix and do
elimination how big a matrix shall I
take two by two you say you three by
three somebody not convinced totally by
two by two
let me do it two by two and then if you
want if you really want a three by three
yellow I'll do it okay here's two by two
two four three seven how's that okay so
what is yeah so let's remember what
elimination does
it subtracts a multiple of that row from
that one to get two to three and the
multiple is two so it knocks out the
four two threes or six so it leaves a 1
and we're oh yeah thanks for allowing me
to do two by two
I've already done it now I've reached
you so here's a and here's you the upper
triangular guy with the pivots on the
diagonal good and then the question is
express that step in matrix language and
the right answer is L times u so the
right answer is that this that this a is
so I'll just erase that letter U is L
times u so what is L L is the lower
triangular guy and it has there the
number that you used here and what was
that I subtracted two of that row from
this so I wanted to there so that would
be I would call that a multiplier I
multiplied Row one by two subtracted to
get that zero and for a two by two
example I was finished okay now I want
to see this so there's L times U what
happened I would like to see how L times
u comes out of this row a column times
row so let me start let me think again
what so the really the point of
elimination what was why did we do this
in the first place
because here we had two coupled
equations they were a couple together we
couldn't solve them instantly that step
of elimination
juice me two down here in this corner
one equation that I've eliminated the
first unknown X from the second equation
so the second equation is zero X plus 1
y equal right hand side and I solve it
immediately okay
so how did I get to that one by one
problem with these guys removed well
yeah just right can I write here the my
parallel way to think of it in it two by
two is pretty small I admit okay
so I start with two three four seven I
want to split it in two I want to get
the first row and column in one piece
something goes there and the other piece
is something there okay
that's what elimination has done it's
taken the original matrix its splitted
these are both ranked one so let's just
first of all you could tell me what goes
in that blank space in the first rank
one matrix so what can I say this in
words the first stage of elimination
pulls off from a so a is some big matrix
it pulls off from a it takes account of
the first column and row so it it it
writes a as here we go as a first column
say column 1 Row 1 plus plus the easy
part the easy part will be a matrix with
all zeros there Oh zeroes there and here
I have a 2
can I call it a - this is my way now to
think about what elimination is really
doing it's starting with an N by n
matrix it's pulling off a rank one
matrix which has gets that column and
that row correct and it gets whatever it
has in here and then the rest of what's
in there is a - you see that we've done
that here the first step got the first
row and column correct and if it's rank
one what number goes there six six and
then this is the rest this is what we
have one size smaller to work on and it
looks like it was seven six has been
used so it's a one that's really I want
to think of this rank one matrix as the
first column of L times the first row of
U and then this guy is the second column
of L times the second row of U I'm okay
I haven't presented this proof in the
class before and for two-by-two it's
looking like overkill to me I mean like
why you don't have to do all that deep
thinking to get to get pieces but my
idea is that it gives the breakdown and
this of course is by our column times
row rule that's Lu so we're we're
starting with a and we're breaking it up
into Lu where Lu the first piece of Lu
is the first column times row and then
the next pieces are the rest of the
matrix
and though was get broken down the next
stage of elimination would break if I
had a 3x3 this stage peeled off the
first column in row then the next stage
would peel off the second the new second
column in row and the third stage would
have the third column in rows just last
pivot does this make any sense to you
you could email me and say it's not that
great but I think it's to see that the
final result of elimination is L times U
is it's there's a little magic in in
seeing what you're doing and I think
this is a way to see what you're doing
that you're you're peeling off a first
part to leave a second part like that
then the second part you would peel off
the second column times the second row
may be divided by the pivot to make it
correct and that would that would put
something in the rest of the box and
then a three would be the rest of that
box okay I'm stopping here I'm glad you
let me do 2x2 since I see that 3x3 would
it would have ruined the day yeah okay a
question or let me pause for a minute so
I've talked about these factorizations
this one we won't see again this one we
will see big-time and this one we will
and this one we will yeah yeah
2 3 & 5 are the ones that we're really
gonna see a lot of questions or thoughts
or okay I guess I want to tell you now
to complete today's moving forward in
this subject the fundamental theorem of
linear algebra the fundamental theorem
of linear algebra okay ready for that or
you may have seen it already because
it's like the highlight of
of this subject of the basic ideas in
this subject right and then maybe I can
after I'd tell you that theorem people
around the world send me homework
problems to do now you would think any
sensible professor would never do those
problems like he would say it's your
problem but I get carried away and I
solve them sometimes
so one came from India last week and it
involved the fundamental theorem of
linear algebra whoever teaching it there
really was on on the ball and well I'll
tell you that problem after after the
fundamental theorem okay
fundamental theorem it's about four
subspaces so I invented the name four
fundamental subspaces so can i list the
four subspaces fundamental basis well we
know one of them already the column
space so for a matrix we're given a
matrix a that's M by end of rank R
that's our that's our normal starting
point so what are those four subspaces
and how are they related and what's
their dimension and what what those a
key fact okay we already know the column
space column space of the matrix and
actually we already know the row space
of a matrix and we have the notation for
that column space of a transpose and
what is the dimension so that was the
key point in the first lecture anybody
who missed the first lecture should go
back to the notes of one point one
for the for the thinking that goes into
the dimension equals what which of those
three numbers do I want to is the
dimension of the column space are or and
what can I say about our right away
compared to M&M yeah less or equal or
could I couldn't have more independent
columns than I have columns so I've got
n columns so our our of them are
independent so our is somewhere less or
equal hopefully equal to n what about
the dimension of the row space how many
independent rows as the matrix got our
thank you that's that's the great fact
with a new proof less time in section
1.1 that those have the same dimension
same dimension which is you know it's
you think okay you look at a simple
example it's true but you know if you if
you're given a matrix that's fifty by
hundred really the fact that those
hundred columns have the same number of
independent ones as those 50 rows that's
that's like great okay now the other
spaces are the null space of the matrix
in of a and just to make everything
naturally symmetric a null space of a
transpose those are the last two those
are the four fundamental subspaces which
you've seen and they're even on the
cover of the linear algebra textbook
okay so what's the null space
the set of solutions to ax equals zero
right no space is all solutions to ax
equals e so the null space has vector
these vectors in the XS the null space
isn't taken from the matrix the row of
the row space in the column space those
those numbers are sitting in the matrix
the null space and the null space of a
transpose are solutions to the word null
is reflecting the fact that that's a
zero and that's what makes it a space
now can you just let me just ask you to
think again what's implied when I say
when I use the word space a space of
vectors I can add yeah
so so you I can do the most important
operations of linear algebra in that
space I can add two vectors here let me
just add them so here I'll have a vector
X and let me say another another one a
vector Y then I do addition I follow the
rules I see that this can be written as
ax plus y is zero plus zero so what have
I learned I've learned that if X is in
the null space and Y is in the null
space then X plus y so the null space is
as you said closed meaning I don't go
outside it if X is in it and Y is in it
then the sum is in it and similarly from
ax equals zero I get to a times C x
equals zero
it's just multiplied by C by a number C
so those two facts that that means I can
do linear algebra I can multiply by
numbers and I can add in other words I
can take
linear combinations that's what you do
with vectors and the point is if i do it
if i take combinations of two null space
guys I'm still in the null space okay so
that's the point of the null space and
well now so now part of the fundamental
theorem is to figure out how many
independent vectors are in the null
space how many solutions independent
solutions does that system of equations
have so that'll be the dimension and I
have to ask you what it is let me draw a
picture while you're thinking about
those spaces it's fantastic to have
these beautiful clean boards okay so
here's my picture of the row space rows
that's the column space of a transpose
and here's my picture of the null space
of a and that's the solutions to ax
equals zero and why have I put these two
together and these two together so the
other pair will be the column space C of
a and null space of a transpose so there
are the four spaces where their
relationship is the fundamental theorem
of linear algebra so first of all what
sorry so I have an M by n matrix so that
tells me that my rows a typical row has
n components right I look at an M by n
matrix let's do it two by three
matrix so if I look at the row space
this is M and this is n so so I see
three the rows have length three and of
course they multiply the X's which also
has length 3 X 1 X 2 X 3 that's why
these are together because they're both
in n-dimensional space then why are
these together because the columns are
in two dimensional space for this
example and null space of a transpose
would be just two components like y 1 y
2 to give zeros so do you see that this
is are these guys are in RN
so that's the first like get things
straight 2 spaces in RN 2 spaces in RM
now then what am I going to ask about
these spaces I guess I already started
asking and didn't wait for an answer
their dimension so this has dimension R
and what's the dimension how many this
is really such a key fact if I have M
equations ax equals zero and if R of
those equations are independent how many
solutions so the dimension of the space
is going to tell me how many solutions
to X into two M equations but really
only are genuine independent equations
in in this system ax equals zero
how many so can I ask the question again
and I want the answer in terms of
M and n are so I have I really have our
equations if I look at a x equals 0 it
looks like M separate equations but but
M minus R of those are just copies or
combinations of others so there are
independent equations so what how many
of I got and that's what I'm gonna write
in here yeah so yeah so X has X has n
components and there are real you know
active equations that they have to
satisfy
and that leaves n minus R that's the key
point that's the key point that there
are n components of X and unknowns in
unknowns and there are are constraints
independent constraints so the those n
you get if I want to satisfy those
constraints that knocks out dimension R
and leaves and minus R so that's the
dimension here and the beauty of the
account is that those two numbers add up
to n everybody's accounted for every
vector has a piece in the row space and
a piece in the null space and that's
there was two pieces give you back the
vector do you see that that's just nice
that the numbers come out right and of
course they come out right here too you
could say just transpose a matrix and
write it right the same thing again
what's the dimension of the column space
equals the column space of the matrix
has dimension R right
and the row this this guy is left out of
some linear algebra books as if it like
it doesn't belong but
and they clear that you know without it
everything is of only 3/4 ders done we
have to have this guy and it's dimension
is Emma - yeah it's yeah that count is
just for a transpose what this count was
for a yeah so we've got those dimensions
are n minus R R and M - yeah you you
know you'll have known this but we need
to see it once again in 2018 before we
start using it now is that the
fundamental theorem is that all all - it
is no there's another piece to the
fundamental theorem which is sort of you
could say the the geometry here I have a
subspace here I have a subspace of this
big n-dimensional space so I visualize
those subspaces as some kind of a plane
an R dimensional plane and an N minus R
dimensional plane and I want to see how
are those two planes connected how are
those two claims connected and let me
get a piece of the blank piece of the
board to remember the final step right
so we've got dimensions R and n - R and
then over here R and M minus R okay this
is for the rows this is for the null
space so this has the rows in it this
has the null the solutions to ax equals
zero what is the beautiful geometry that
how do you visualize those two spaces
how do you visualize let me take an
example
but a B 1 2 4 2 4 8 sorry about that
you see it's a hooked up example so this
is 2 by 3 so there n is 3 what's in the
null space of this matrix can I can you
see a vector that solves a x equals 0
and in fact how many will there be
what's yeah what's our for this matrix
just tell me all the good stuff for that
example M is 2 and is 3 and R is 1 1
everybody sees one for the rank the rows
are dependent it's there's only one
independent row the columns are
dependent there's only like every column
is a multiple of one - it's a rank one
matrix ok what about it so it's row
space has dimension 1 and it's null
space has dimension 2 2 so cuz n minus R
will be 2 so I'm looking for a couple of
vectors that both give 0 I believe
they're I think I've only got one
independent row there so I should be
able to find two different vectors that
are that solve ax equals 0 so what's a
solution to ax equals 0 0 91 0 minus 2 1
yeah that works and what's an
independent solution for 0 I don't throw
me off for 0 and
- one yeah that looks good that looks
good
and then the claim is that every
solution would be a combination of those
two and that this is how many there are
and now it's the geometry I'm completing
so we have like two minutes left in this
lecture you just have to tell me how
what's the relation between the these
guys in the row space and that guy in
the null space what's the relation
between the rows of a and the solutions
to ax equals zero between if you see it
if you saw that vector in that vector
well a times X is zero now so what does
that tell us
well what do we see for the for the
relation between 1 2 4 and 0 - 2 1 they
are orthogonal terrific yes orthogonal I
test by the dot product 0 - 4 4 add to 0
yes so so the and that's a completely
general fact when I look at ax equals 0
it's telling me that X is orthogonal to
the rows did you see that
you just put it in again here if I look
at ax a has a bunch of rows X has one
column and I get zeros that's the point
of the null space and that equation is
just say that Row 1 is orthogonal
because that's the dot product of Row 1
with X so here's Row 1 Row 2 over 3 and
Row 4 with X the rows with X and I get
zeros so the point is then these two
spaces are at 90 degree angles that's a
really a neat picture of the four
subspaces and these two are for the same
reason at 90 degree angles off in M
dimensional space so this is this is the
fundamental theorem
of linear algebra to see that the
dimensions come out right and the
geometry comes out right yeah and then
now next time following the notes and I
have a few more copies of the of the
hand that one hand out will we'll move
on quickly next week to eigenvalues and
positive definite matrices good this is
really linear algebra moving on